Доходи українців значно нижчі, ніж у мешканців Євросоюзу,
але тарифи на газ в Україні найвищі в Європі.
Про це заявила Юлія Тимошенко під час зустрічі з мешканцями Кривого Рогу.
А як нам в Україні, де в 16 разів нижчі доходи,
поставити найвищі в Європі тарифи?
DW вирішила перевірити
Згідно з оприлюдненим на сайті Євростату даними,
у середньому по ЄС кубометр газу, включно з податками,
коштує близько 20 гривень.
Ціна на "блакитне паливо" варіюється в залежності від країни
і подекуди може відрізнятися у кілька разів.
Приміром, у другій половині 2017 року
найдорожчий газ купували мешканці Швеції.
У перерахунку на гривні кубометр "блакитного палива"
споживачам цієї країни обійшовся у майже 37 гривень.
Далі у рейтингу з дорожнечі цього природного ресурсу -
Іспанія, Данія та Італія - близько 30 гривень.
Найдешевшим серед держав Євросоюзу газ у Румунії -
населення цієї країни платило близько 10 гривень за кубометр.
Тим часом в Україні "блакитне паливо" коштувало найменше -
- трохи менше 7 гривень за куб.
І воно лишатиметься найдешевшим, порівняно з іншими країнами Євросоюзу,
навіть і після підвищення тарифів до 8 з половиною гривень.
Таким чином, найнижчими ціни на газ
є саме у країнах Центрально-Східної Європи, констатують у Євростаті.
Там наголошують, що ціна залежить від низки чинників,
зокрема, і геополітичної ситуації,
національного енергетичного балансу, видатків на охорону довкілля,
погодних умов або акцизних зборів та оподаткування.
Утім, низька, порівняно з іншими європейськими країнами, вартість газу
зовсім не означає, що він дешевий для українців,
адже середній рівень доходів населення в Україні залишається низьким.
Тому фахівці радять також оцінювати, скільки "блакитного палива"
на свою зарплату чи пенсію може купити українець,
а скільки - громадянин ЄС.
Найбільш доступним газ в Європі є для громадян Люксембургу -
середньостатистичний мешканець цієї країни
може придбати понад 8 тисяч кубометрів газу на місяць.
Усе тому, що в цій країні відносно невисокі ціни на "блакитне паливо",
а середня зарплата є однією з найвищих в Європі.
Водночас, українці за свою середню зарплату
можуть дозволити собі лише близько тисячі кубів газу.
А якщо врахувати те, що мінімальна пенсія, яку отримують мільйони громадян,
складає лише 1435 гривень,
для пенсіонерів ціна на газ іще менш підйомна,
ніж для тих, хто працює.
В Україні ціна на природний газ для населення нижча,
ніж у країнах Європи.
У цій частині твердження Юлії Тимошенко є хибним.
Проте навіть попри відносно низьку ціну "блакитне паливо"
з урахуванням купівельної спроможності населення
залишається надто дорогим для українців.